are you a giants guy are you a yankees
guy
i was a jets guy most of my life
everyone
yeah nobody's perfect well you know what
i i'm a loyal guy but i left the team
because of management they just never
put a good team on the field for how
many years so you're a jets guy yeah
what nick now let me tell you you're an
island are you a ranger guy or an
islander i don't like hockey i'm not a
big hockey guy he doesn't like
but i'll tell you what happened you know
with my work with the nfl i uh i visited
the uh patriots
and i spent time with them addressed the
team and i became a huge patriot fan
because i love belichick i met brady uh
matt patricia who is a defensive
coordinator became a good friend and
that would get me killed in new york
faster than quitting tomorrow wow you
cannot be a patriot fan in new york
that's for sure how long ago was that
visit uh about three years ago oh so
three or four years ago yeah current
height of brady everything broke my
heart when the tuna went to uh to the
patriots the tuna with the patriots just
never said ourselves yeah the big tuna
yeah
and i gotta tell you brady uh he sat in
the front row and he asked some very
intelligent questions she was uh
i i just got a lot of respect for him
not only on the field and were you a
yankees guy mets guy diehard yankee fan
okay
what's the scene in speaking of
congratulations to derek sanderson jeter
number two
derek jeter going to the hall of fame
you know who showed up to his uh to his
uh ceremony all his girlfriends michael
jordan
jordan jordan and patrick ewing showed
up can you imagine like jordan shows up
you're not even in his game he shows up
to your ceremony he's recently divorced
and like adam said where jeter goes uh
you know party treats follow what was
the scene in bronx tale where uh de niro
says mickey mantle doesn't pay your
bills
mickey mantle cry yeah
milky mickey mantle cry yeah that
cartoon your father can't pay the bills
that's nicki minni cart today
graded psa 10 is worth 20 million
dollars 20 million dollars three of them
left in the world bro when you tell me
these stories it's amazing i used to put
baseball cards in the spokes of my of my
he was my idol he made me a yankee
norton dimaggio as an italian really
yeah i was younger with demacho
godzimano was my you know was my guy why
though what what
what kind of a player was he like how
did he win the fans over he just you
know everything about him i mean he was
a five tool player he could do
everything right if that guy
was healthy if he didn't have the knee
problem and all you know the ailments
that he had if you saw his routine in
getting ready for a game you wouldn't
believe it
but i i guess what happened i was at
yankee stadium one time the old stadium
and mantle hit two home runs they were
playing detroit he had two home runs and
he made two catches in center field that
i can if i close my eyes i can see it
both of them were over the head like
this right up against the wall just kept
running straight for the wall and made
that catch i don't know how he did it he
never looked back never looked back you
were at that game i was at the game wow
so you watch man you watch man of play
oh yeah yeah
my dad's being able to say many times
now you were a brooklyn guy and you like
the yankees you want to dodge a guy no
no you know why
because whenever when they left brooklyn
all i ever heard was those effing
dodgers you don't leave brooklyn yeah
everybody turned on him but my
grandmother prayed for gil hodges every
day for us yeah well
it was it was a good guy he was a good
uh manager for the match yeah michael
who's your top five all-time baseball i
mean i know this is off topic but you
said mantle so what do you what do you
want amazing
oh maize mage was you know amazing did
you watch me
i shouldn't match play yeah you've seen
mace play yes i mean that's well we
talked about this i know we did i'm
curious to know what he's going to say
well one of the things about me is that
a lot of people don't know so some of
the old-timers that uh that i used to
talk about 450. 600 660 home runs
they're like it doesn't even do him
justice yeah he played in the poll
grounds it was 450 to dead center and
then he went out to san francisco where
he had to deal with gale force winds
blowing in from left field
yeah so he was she was amazing so you
got mantle you got maize you got jeter i
love jeter i mean how could you know you
know jeter was the
the player of the moment whenever you
needed something he was there november
yeah who rounds out your top five oh
gosh that's hard i mean they were for me
they're all yankees because i'm a
die-hard yankee fan but i i can recite
the whole you know yankee team you know
scouring
i don't want to go into it because it
makes me sad but i miss them but uh
because i'm so disappointed in that and
now oh god the way they're playing now
yeah george is probably rolling over in
his grave they've got no heart did you
ever meet steinbrenner i met
steinbrenner twice
how was that yeah i loved the guy
loved him i mean he didn't take any
nonsense was he off the camera like how
he is on grammar great guy off camera
okay is he like a trump personality yes
big-hearted guy
you you described him right just like
trump big-hearted guy but nothing
intimidated him he didn't care how great
a player you were he wanted to get the
most out of them and he uh motivated
them in any way that he thought and it
was very effective who's the skipper he
fired two or three times billy billy
martin it's great when they went out and
then yogi tried to do the same thing
with yogi and yogi said he'd never go
back yogi berra five foot eight
ten world series one of the greatest
catchers of all time i mean how could
you not lose one of the greatest
wordsmiths of all time yeah comedian
yeah yeah nobody goes there anymore it's
too busy wait ten world series
championships or yes ten world
humility right humility to move to the
outfield because elston howard was
coming up
molly five foot eight
that's a time when the yankees were
absolutely beloved they were they were
amazing like the whole country loved
them now it's
very polarized nobody loves the game you
love them i hated them i was one of the
two you know you loved him but dude the
late 90s were a halcyon time also man
like the the yankees red sox rivalry was
just must watch tv i cannot tell you the
last time i had my calendar mark to
watch a baseball game i love baseball
but i can't tell you the last time when
was the last time what what team got you
interested the braves
is is it the player was it mcguire sosa
yeah it was why sosa 98 uh no you know i
i look i love the game when i was a kid
the mets were like
unreal like the the late 80s mets were
like they were rock stars and then 86
minutes you gotta remember ken griffey
jr the crossover appeal to ken griffey
jr i mean imagine kids today wanting to
go buy sneakers because of a baseball
player like nobody even knows who mike
trout is you had to have the griffeys
you had to have the sneakers the kid you
had to have the swing man like you know
like it's hard enough these guys are so
cleats now i mean you know you had to
have ken griffey junior baseball on
super nintendo that game was unreal you
know you were a big juan gonzalez guy
die hard die hard texas rangers fan i
was a die hard tech he was six two and a
half
two eighteen i had similar uh uh
physique similar swing and i just loved
this game
i played with wong gong in in spring
training and i've never seen anybody hit
embattling practice i've never seen
anybody did he make you a rangers fan oh
die hard that's right yeah from 91-92
oh yeah when he came in because sosa was
a rookie win 1988-89
he was a rookie in 1990 he came
i don't know what it was second or third
year he had 28 home runs i think he even
i think sosa got drafted by the white
sox and then he got traded to the cubs
and gonzalez came in and i started
following leo franco julio franco was
also uh kevin brown yeah i have a very
controversial uh statement here on this
there we go steroids were raised they
were great for baseball
they really were they i don't know who
was hurt by it i don't know who these
guys were throwing 100 miles an hour and
they were hitting the ball seven
thousand feet it was it was an exciting
game they were running fast it was
hardball they used to say hardball is
back one of the greatest commercials
ever made is tom glavin and uh greg
maddox looking at uh michelle pfeiffer
walks past them to get mark maguire's
autograph chicks take the long ball and
instead of just pumping it and they're
there that's commercial yeah
i remember chicks dig the longbow it was
just a great time for sports sosa
mcguire hugging it out but they got
those little dinosaur arms because
they're so big trying to hug each other
it was it was a great speculation he was
emotional when mcguire hit the home run
he picked up his son
he comes down the place is going crazy
the home run almost didn't go by the way
yeah the seventh year it was just a line
drive to the left none of those guys
make it into the hall of fame because
we're talking steroids but bud selig's
in there cashing all that paper from all
those years but
he ruined the game with the strike he
ruined the game and then he gets to go
into the hall of fame because these guys
brought it all the way back man i think
what you're saying is let's make
steroids great again
is that what you're trying to say any
kids that are watching this don't do it
but what i'm saying is is that the guys
that did do it it was a pretty fun
product to watch there's nobody that
could tell me that they watched late 90s
early 2000s baseball said all the the
game's better you know though you know
the whole thing when they say like hey
if i did steroids that also wouldn't
stroll olympia i'd also win you know be
a bodybuilder oh i fight the steroids
you can do all the steroids in the world
there's no way you can hit a 95 mile for
asphalt harry potter
where's the controversy nobody has yet
proven that the steroids made you hit
more home runs
i mean really you you can't say that for
a fact yeah and and i mean the steroids
helped you get stronger and helped you
you know but and the pictures
i'll push back a little bit on this when
gary sheffield hit a home run on a check
swing
you know something
and uh gary just goes back you're like
wait yeah what the hell just guys do you
remember that or no i do remember i got
one even worse glenn allen hill breaking
his bat
and then slamming the bat down in in
chicago and the ball carries carries
characters glenn allen hill was a
that's not to say either of these guys
were yeah doing anything anyway
why is every why is every pitcher now
pitching 99 100 miles an hour yeah no
it's not steroids i think it's more you
can get away more with
hrt today uh growth hormone than you can
with steroids it's easier to get away
with growth hormone today yes there's
some you know people the conspiracies
out there about lebron what he's on how
he takes care of his body
it's not creatine doing that you know
it's not the uis is doing that there's
something that's going on that maybe we
don't know about yeah but uh it is what
it is i mean listen i i don't mind
lebron staying healthy to play 20 plus
years i think it's better for sports
yeah i'd much rather get them 20 years
in 12 years so if you're figuring out a
way to keep the youth
uh juice going where you can like you
yourself going by the way yesterday
we're having dinner i'm sitting there i
order uh what did i order everything
okay no no i ordered myself you ordered
the the parmesan also real quick one of
the most baller things i've ever seen in
my life this is the first time in my
life i've ever sat down at a table and
the food was waiting for us that's the
carolina moment yes
the appetizer was waiting and then
michael his food shows up yeah and his
wife says watch him finish that and
finish half my plate michael no joe
quietly he's talking to everybody
this
massive bone i don't know what it was
right
triceratops he finishes that then it
finishes and he's and then sweets comes
yeah i guess i'll try a little bit of
this and then
that's gone and then the next thing you
know dessert anyway so he said something
to me in the middle of dinner he goes
yeah i i probably i get i eat a lot i
could probably eat more than gerard
that's
with him with it
and his wife said you heard that michael
francis wants to go toe-to-toe
gerard finished the dessert took it home
on the way home he finished it and then
he ran two miles this morning on the
beach the bus boys cleaning up the place
talking too much pat goes keep eating
your sweets
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]